let's start with Lisa Marie's eldest
daughter Riley you know her new chapter
and the new role that has Riley
channeling her rock star roots
[Music]
it's really emotional to to have people
care so much about your family
three days after her mother was laid to
rest that's Riley Elvis's granddaughter
in a first look at the project she
finished shooting last May how much of
everything do you really want to know
from that classic shawl to the 70s sound
Riley is giving the spirit of Stevie
Nicks
Riley performs all her own songs in
Daisy Jones in the six which was adapted
from a bestseller its executive produced
by Reese Witherspoon and Promises to
take Riley's career Next Level I was
brought up to be like very private
um so I'm still kind of like that the
Prime video limited series debuts March
3rd no word on how Riley will handle the
media tour as the new mom faces life
without her mom she works been working
since 13 very hard the 33 year old
inherited Graceland along with her twin
sisters it's clear she also inherited
her mama's singing voice
do you watch and you kind of think of
what you went through in your life and
do you try to watch over her or you're
like honey do it I am very protective
and worried but I don't get in the way
in 2013 Riley co-starred with Justin
Timberlake in the music video for TKO
what do you think of the new video with
your daughter I thought it was great it
is also very dark I mean I'm not a
stranger to dark
at the moment she's in Africa shooting
Mad Max and
um I couldn't be more proud in 2016
Riley was nominated for a Golden Globe
for her performance in the girlfriend
experience how'd your mom take it
um she was very very proud yeah yeah
most recently Riley played opposite
Chris Pratt in the terminal list what
were some of the advice that your
parents gave you to not desire attention
or fame to my mom like that was like
awful she didn't want me to be like a
celebrity kid I'm just proud you know so
proud Riley actually didn't have to
technically audition for her role in the
first Magic Mike director Stephen
Soderbergh saw her tape and that was it
do you keep in touch with her at all I
mean yeah she's been going through a lot
yeah yeah all the love it's not anything
that anyone wants to have to go through